they're not very important to America
but they should be the fact that unions
have been pushed into a marginal
position as a political fact unions
remain very important in other advanced
countries and not not just ones that are
far away and very different from us
unions are very important in Canada
unions in the 60s Canada and the US were
comparably unionized that 30% of the
workforce Canada is still almost as
unionized as it was then the United
States the unions have been largely
crushed and crushed as the right word
because it was hostile dissent often the
illegal union busting by employers
because the political environment was
one in which open season had been
declared on union organizers there's no
reason people say oh you know
manufacturing phases global competition
well that's true and places some limits
on what unions can achieve in
manufacturing but why shouldn't Walmart
be unionized because nothing that that
says that we couldn't have large
corporations in the service sector part
of a unionized workforce and I think
unions which is very important as a
counterweight to two other forces in the
society there's not there are not many
ways in which ordinary workers can be
effective in bargaining effective in
politics unions is the best ways to do
that
you